foreign
[Music]
is like a blank canvas you decide how to
configure virtual machines or VMS using
combination of CPU memory disk and
networking and for those of you who want
to think of further I've got a good news
you can even configure network
interfaces
see by default every VM instance in a
virtual private cloud or VPC network has
a single network interface however you
can configure an instance with multiple
network interfaces
in this video we will learn how to
create a compute engine VM with multiple
network interfaces and examine its use
cases
to begin with let's look at the
prerequisites that you need to complete
before creating a VM with multiple
network interfaces
first ensure that each network interface
is attached to a different VPC Network
either Standalone or shared VPC Network
next ensure that each network interface
belongs to a subnet whose IP range
doesn't overlap with the subnets of any
other interface
finally you must either have one of the
following rules project owner or editor
rule or compute.instance admin.v1 role
if you are using a shared VPC
architecture you should have the
compute.network user role add the shared
VPC host project level or add the shared
VPC subnet level
be aware that there are some limitations
or caveats with VMS that have multiple
network interfaces you can configure the
network interface only when you create
the instance network interfaces can be
deleted only when the instance is
deleted IP forwarding can be enabled
only at the VM level and cannot be
applied to individual interfaces
keep in mind the number of virtual
network interfaces scales with the
number of vcpus with a minimum of 2 and
a maximum of 8. refer to the table to
determine how many network interfaces
can be attached to an instance
now let's dive into a demo and create a
VM instance with three network
interfaces from three different VPC
Networks
in the Google Cloud console go to the
compute engine page
click create instance
specify the instance name let's say
instance minus multi minus Nick
select the preferred region or leave it
as the default since we are creating
more than two network interfaces we will
need at least more than two vcpus let's
select E2 standard 4 as our machine type
keep the remaining configurations as
default and move on to the networking
section scroll down to the advanced
options and select networking
click the default interface and verify
the configurations
this is our first network interface Nic
0. that will be created in the default
VPC Network
click add interface to add a new network
interface select the VPC Network and
subnet to use for the network interface
IP address
click done
repeat the steps to add the third
network interface from the third VPC
Network
click done and then click create
congratulations the VM instance is
created with three network interfaces
now let's test our VM for connectivity
to different VPC Networks use the SSH
command to connect to the VM instance
that we just created Run the sudo
ifconfig command to list all the network
interfaces on this VM
there are three interfaces one for each
VPC Network
execute the Ping command to VM a with IP
address
10.128.1.3 from default Network there
you go we are able to connect to vme
next test the connectivity to other VMS
that are already created in their
respective VPC Networks vmb with IP
address
10.2.2.3 from VPC Network B
and vmc with IP address
10.3.3.3 from VPC Network C
great the connectivity tests are
successful from VM with three network
interfaces
multiple network interfaces can be
really useful in a handful of situations
especially for perimeter isolation
multiple network interfaces can be used
to isolate public facing services from
an internal Network and its services
you can configure one interface to
accept public facing traffic and another
to handle back-end private traffic that
has more restrictive access controls
network security networking and security
virtual appliances such as web
application firewall Security
application Level firewalls and Van
accelerators are usually configured with
multiple virtual interfaces be aware of
how the DNS resolution works with
instances having multiple network
interfaces
all the Google Cloud VMS have an
internal host name that looks something
like this
when a DNS query is executed with the
internal hostname it results to the
primary network interface next0 of the
instance
if Nik 0 is attached to a VPC Network
that is different from the VPC network
of the instance issuing the DNS query
then the DNS query will fail
for more details about VM with multiple
network interfaces check out the
following documents
thanks for watching the video
[Music]